greetings from austria
and uh also sorry taranka is jalapa i
think you got timed out but it was like
a
misclick i presume
um okay let's play let's play stafford
keep up the fun openings also
mg gentlemen hello from austria welcome
back
also shout out to vampire chicken whose
variation i'm kind of
about to play if i play c3 we'll have
the
the vampire chicken magical stockfish
variation oh h3
is um this is what carlson played
like the one time he played against
stafford and he also played bishop e3
which is just not a good move and now
this is
uh this is pleasant for black
i remember preparing this a little bit
deeper
i think queenie five
queen e5 castling knight g4
or is it h4 immediately
no i think it's queen e5
there's some issue with casting it might
be bishop h3 actually
this is another line like i prepared
probably a month or two ago
after seeing carlson's game
um
i thought bishop 3 is a better move
because now if takes takes queen g3 king
here
i think this is close to winning knight
g4
at the very least it's a draw um
i'm gonna play for a win whatever
happens
i don't think white's actually gonna
take it
oh okay i'm bad at predicting the future
so i might as well take the pawn i could
take the other pawn
too but at any point i can play this
move
a knight of three then i fork
now it's just a question do i want the
king on
wait i have this move too opponent wants
to draw no thank you
rook h6 might be the crushing move here
it's funny like i was considering this
this this
rook h6 was the last move i i considered
but this is hard to stop
if king tries to run it can't really run
or
hide i would play this preventing the
king from going to e1 and then
then it's a party
a very sly draw offer
okay so check
how do i do this check
i think it's force mate if here it's
made in a few
if here it's made in one
okay you have to force the king to f1 so
there's no blocking on the first rank
okay another nice kind of opening trap
type game
my roommates are just getting into the
game and want me to teach
them some openings what would you
recommend
oh um
it depends what they're into like if
they want something aggressive or solid
uh london is easy to teach any
system-based opening is sometimes
easiest to teach like london or
stonewall
or king's indian or kali zugertort
if you want to fund some fun gambits
maybe the staffer gambit
um and share my videos
um was knight g4 winning
uh yeah i wasn't sure about knight g4
because knight f3
maybe it's still just much better
because i would win e3 but
this seemed like the cleaner approach so
quickly analyze
ah engine wants this this and then
knight g4 and that knight of three
rook h6 here it's harder to understand
um i do want to show
[Music]
like though the reason why i studied
this line
kind of in depth is because if you
checked the
games in lee chess after h3
the top game was a carlson game
which featured queen d4 and carlson
played bishop e3 here
it was against a very popular turkish
chess streamer
satranche youtube
and
[Music]
yeah they went into the same line okay
so queen e5 was played
and carlson played knight f3 here
so maybe real quick i'll share my
i'll share my secret prep my secret
stafford prep
if i can find it i'm gradually working
on like a very extensive stafford gambit
um
kind of database of of analysis
so this is what it looks like so far
i think this is it yeah this is it
okay so um
yeah we can see right here
i was working on this like um i guess
back in november
and oh i didn't even have casting in
this file
but casting if we just check
stockfish probably just bishop h3 is
yeah it's already pretty much winning
for black
because then knight g4 is hard to stop
okay so another nice uh nice opening
that might also go on youtube can never
have enough
stafford gambit content
um yeah what carlson played was knight
f3
and then
like the reason why i prepared this kind
of deeply is because if i ever play
carlsen
i would definitely play stafford i want
to be prepared for what he's played
before
um and the improvement here is h4
to then get the knight potentially to g3
so goes on youtube uh hello to youtube
you can follow on twitch if you have
amazon prime you can subscribe on twitch
for free and support the channel